welcome everyone to using graph neural
networks to embrace the dependency
within your data
i hope you're all feeling spritely and
full of energy this morning um
so to introduce myself i work as a
machine learning engineer at go data
driven in the netherlands in amsterdam
i have a background in data science
worked uh several years as a data
scientist
had a bit of an identity crisis because
i really liked engineering and so now
i'm trying to combine the two so a bit
of data science and the engineering side
of things
and quite recently i've become
fascinated by grass and their
problem-solving abilities which is what
this talk is about
aside for that i'm also a really big
cycling enthusiast some would call it an
obsession they may be right
um
and yeah apart from that i live in
amsterdam with my girlfriend and two
cats or
sadly i was unable to get any pictures
of cats in the presentation couldn't
quite make it work
so the agenda for today is
to go through an example use case which
should highlight why graphs are useful
we'll also go
go into the theory behind how we do
calculations with graphs and why that's
advantageous compared to some other
common approaches
and hopefully we'll get some time at the
end for some questions too
so one of the main aims of this talk is
to understand how
sometimes we don't factor in
certain features or dynamics of our
problem
and how this can ultimately impact the
predictive performance of our models
whilst the particular example in this
talk relates to graphs there is a wider
point which i hope becomes clear
behind how sometimes the way we simplify
things perhaps misses
intricacies of our problems
so the motivation behind this is twofold
firstly
one of the reasons i enjoy graphs is
because they are interesting from
different perspectives that's regarding
databases which store graph data
there's also the
engineering pipelines which are a bit
quirky
and also the underlying models and
mathematics themselves
so as a data scientist is now working in
engineering it's nice for me to still be
able to focus on all those different
aspects
and after having explored the open
source tools that now support this kind
of work they seem to be in a pretty
mature state and so productionizing this
kind of work is more achievable now and
not something that will just remain
dormant in a notebook on your computer
secondly so
i work for go data driven it's a data
and machine learning consultancy
therefore we get we're very lucky to
work on a range of products
projects with different companies
different technologies different use
cases
and so it's nice to kind of develop a
holistic view of how data projects are
executed in
different companies
and so one of the things i started to
notice across different projects was
a sort of rigidity in the way we
sometimes approach problems
and that largely kind of comes from how
our data looks like at the source
and
sometimes we perhaps use the same
approach or the same tool same framework
for different problems problems which
have different characteristics
uh characteristics that are perhaps
ignored
so the best way to highlight this is by
looking at an example use case so we're
in the beautiful city of london
and i want us to think about
a bike sharing scheme so let's imagine
that we're operating a bike sharing
scheme in this city
and we would like to expand this into
new locations
so it's been working quite well in some
of the locations and now we want to
further expand it
now the different types of
kind of challenges here one of the
things we want to do is predict the
demand for these new locations so we can
match the supply
or we perhaps we want to categorize the
type of demand it will have so is it
going to be serving mostly
office workers who are going to be using
at the rush hour periods or perhaps it's
at a tourist location where you have
more consistent demand throughout the
day in the summer
quite a few different scenarios you
could do with this particular use case
but we're going to focus on just trying
to predict the demand at those locations
so let's think about what our unknowns
are
it's been a while since i've lived in
london so apologies if i make a
geographical error
so we're already operating this scheme
at some locations right so there's
locations at the top and we want to
expand to some new locations so those at
the bottom
for our existing locations we have some
known demand
some some values
and for our new locations we want to
predict that value
and we can obtain some characteristics
some features about our locations
something which gives some insight into
what is there
whether there's offices shops tourist
attractions
or even whether alternative modes of
transport are available at those
locations and that's kind of represented
by the green block
so this is quite a familiar way of
framing the problem we see this all the
time we have our data points
we have some features which describe our
problem and some targets
a natural separation of what the
training data is and then the data on
which we want to do the
predictions
and even outside this particular use
case of bite sharing is quite a common
way of framing a problem
and at this particular point you can
quite easily throw this into any popular
classifier or regression algorithm
you can imagine the green blocks is your
the green block is your input data your
so-called x
y is your target
i think that works with almost any
psychic learn
classifier
but what does this particular way of
framing the problem miss
i think it's also important to
understand why we sometimes frame a
problem in this way and why this is how
our data looks like
it's usually stored in some data
warehouse somewhere maybe some some
bucket some flat file
it's ended up there through some
pipeline
and then yeah perhaps it started out
life in a transactional database where
data is all very tabular
and there's many advantages to this
approach it's quite effective works for
a lot of a lot of reasons
but sometimes it may miss things
so
i would ask are there potential dynamics
or features of this problem that we miss
by
this approach
are we encoding all of the dynamics
for example
are there relationships between these
data points that could contain useful
information and context
for for this prediction task
for example some of some pairs of these
locations are only separated by
a couple of tube swaps or maybe the new
fancy elizabeth line
not yet used it
um
good to know
so that's that's quite useful to know
about the
about how these data points relate to
each other but in this particular way
it's quite hard to encode that
information
and also if we think about how
busy these
locations are on certain days or certain
times of the day of the day and how that
impacts the other locations and how that
flows
that's all quite useful information
context to try and have but how do we
incorporate our model to use it
we may think of just
adding some extra features which then
tries to encode something about
neighboring locations
but then this is what what kind of
information do you add here
this is also quite cumbersome to do
for example some of these are more
concentrated locations they have a lot
of surrounding locations
others are perhaps more isolated and so
this particular way is yeah quite tricky
to to get back to work
and that's where graphs come in
we can see that this problem has a
spatial element to it
and in fact even if there's no explicit
spatial element the fact that sometimes
our data points may have relationships
with each other means we can define our
problem as a graph
where we have nodes and edges
i hope the geography is correct here
roughly
i did check in google maps
so we've arranged these locations based
on their rough location to each other
the edges between them correspond to
whether or not people
in this particular use case cycle
between these two locations
now you can see that we've simplified
things a bit here
for the sake of brevity we could define
an edge between every pair of these
nodes because of course it's possibly
cycle
from all of the locations
but
for now we're just going to assume we're
only considering the very popular route
so maybe the signal between two really
far regions is really low and we can
just ignore it for now
so the edges the relationships they can
be trivial so a very common use case of
social media right whether we're friends
or
followers
or it can be a bit more abstract for
example similarity between two nodes
and in fact what we encode into our
relationships doesn't have to be a
single value
it can encode many different things for
example it could be the distance between
the two locations
can be the time taken to cycle between
them the time taken to maybe get the new
fancy line between them
all of which provides useful context for
our problem
it can be
this one is not yeah
yeah so you we can get onto that later
but those where you have bi-directional
uh information and different types of
nodes and different relationships
um
that's still an active error of research
just because the math is more
complicated than the simple case
so we can see our edge can be
represented by a vector with multiple
values and so there's
a whole range of information we can
encode
in there
so how is this useful
we can imagine a scenario if two
locations are served well by some
some existing public transport
then perhaps that's already a choice
people can make and there's no need to
use the bike sharing scheme but if
they're quite badly connected
for example someone like camberwell
where i'm staying at the moment
yeah public transport doesn't really
exist there
or it's very slow
so that's that's quite useful to know
uh in the context of the other locations
and our particular our nodes the
locations themselves they also have some
features which describe some information
about them this could be about what's
present there whether
uh there's retail stores offices
a tube stop or a bus
stop and how is this useful so you can
imagine if it's mostly offices then that
says something about the type of demand
it's going to have what time that demand
is going to be
uh likewise with retail stores as the
source can have its own patterns
so by now i hope you can see there's
a nice use case for why graphs are
useful and how we can you know there's
two different ways of framing the
problem
um and how
in this particular way we can start to
encode some more trickier aspects of our
problem in this way
and hopefully you can also begin to
think about your own respective domains
and think you know
do my data points have relationships
between them and i'll be encoding them
in our work
perhaps there are no relationships and
in which case you're just thinking what
is this guy rambling on about
and so now we have this graph of nodes
which is our locations our relationships
and our labels as before the demand that
each of those locations
and a natural separation of what we're
trying to predict and what we already
know
so now i want to take a bit of a step
back out of this use case and talk about
what types of problems we can solve once
we have a problem defined as a graph
the first one is known as a node
prediction which is what we're trying to
do where we're trying to predict
something at the node level
so here for example there's a
classification example some nodes are
one others are zero
the green one on the right hand side we
want to know which one it is
it can be a real valued number or a
classification
and there's also link prediction where
we try and predict something at the edge
level so whether or not two pairs of
nodes have a connection or not
for example if i was
to create a
a social media account on twitter
twitter know some information about me
they may want to try and predict yeah
whether or not i'm going to follow trump
uh for the avoidance of doubt i'm not
the process of doing this type of
prediction is a bit trickier has added
complexities
that you don't have in the node
prediction case
so
one of the challenges is as you can
imagine in a really large graph with
lots of nodes most things don't have a
relationship it's very few actual
connections
which means if you just predict no
relationship everything you have a good
accuracy and so that bias of course is
problematic
and so there's several approaches to
overcome this by a kind of
some heuristic approach where you can
sample which negative cases you do take
and which positive cases you do take so
there's a balance
and there's a added complexity that
in graph neural networks you typically
encode a graph
into some other representation but for
the link prediction you then have to
kind of decode it back into a matrix
which defines the connectivity which
we'll also get onto later
and there's also graph level prediction
where you have multiple graphs and you
want to try you want to try and classify
a graph as a whole
so an interesting example of this is
from the chemistry world where you have
a molecule and you're trying to
determine determine whether it's
poisonous or not
so molecule can be represented as a
graph the nodes are their particles and
the edges are the bonds between them so
there's covalent bond hydrogen bond
and then you try to predict whether it's
poisonous with the assumption that
there's some substructure within there
that determines whether it's going to
poison you
goes without saying don't try this at
home of course
so those are the three main types of
problems there are also other problems
for example
in a really large network you may want
to try and predict which sub-region is
influencing another part of the network
this is used in fraud detection so
you're trying to find out which node is
in
in a kind of transaction situation where
you have lots of money going everywhere
you want to find out which particular
set of nodes are influencing others
or may you find anomalies in there
so by a graph i mean something which is
defined with seven
there's your appearing include triangles
meaning you know
things going around in circles
yeah that's possible
that's possible yeah
so
i've seen it being used in the
in the academic space with regards to
the floor detection i'm not sure if it's
uh yeah how feasible it is in the in the
real case
so back to our problem
uh which we have which is a node
prediction in our case where we try and
predict demand at a particular node
so now we have a graph with nodes and
edges but how do we do calculations with
this and where do the neural networks
come into play
so we define a few matrices in order to
encode this problem to make it more
tractable
first one is called the adjacency matrix
so if we have six nodes then our matrix
has six rows and six columns
and this defines the connectivity of our
graph
the values are one if two nodes have a
connection
uh and zero otherwise
you probably notice
most graphs will have lots of zeros in
this so typically in the implementations
you don't do matrix calculations in the
normal way because you have lots of
useless zero calculations
and so the implementations usually only
define pairs of positive cases and then
do the calculations from there
so if you have a really large graph and
a really large matrix
whilst the matrix multiplication is um
kind of happening it's implemented in a
different way so just to look out for
when you come across the frameworks that
support this work
there's also the diagonal matrix
so
a value along the diagonal and each
value corresponds to how many edges are
incident at that node
and these two define the architecture of
our graph
so ignoring features for now but just
the architecture
and usually what's done is
uh we subtract the matrix from before
the adjacency matrix from this matrix
to give our laplacian
reason we do this is because l our
laplacian has some interesting features
uh which make yeah certain types of
linear algebra dispossible with those
matrices
it also encodes the information from dna
but in a single matrix which is
convenient
we also have our node features
so
information about each particular node
number of rows is also the number of
nodes but then the columns is
arbitrary how many other features you
use to define your
uh
your your node
and likewise with the edge so
how many features you want to encode in
the edges that's how many columns you
end up there
so these four are the main
matrices we need for
for
using graph neural networks
and yeah now you can see these are more
typically shaped objects on which we can
do calculations
these are completely separate
yeah
yeah so it's only um a feature which
describes a relationship between the two
nodes whereas the node features is a
feature which describes just the node so
it doesn't take into account what's
nearby
now the reason for setting up our
problem in this way is the fact that
there's some spatial element to the
problem
so
if we take a look at one specific
portion of the graph and we look at
nearby nodes and edges our assumption is
that there's some useful information in
the nearby regions that is useful
for for our
our problem
for example
if we want to understand the demand of a
potential bike showing scheme in this
new location
then knowing about the scheme in nearby
locations is useful
for
for their new location
as mentioned before if the two locations
are already served well by other other
means then that's good to
know so if we think about our initial
graph let's consider a single node
the it's not very well highlighted but
the the node in the middle is green the
rest are blue
how do we get that single node to get
information from its surrounding
locations
let's say we want to consider a small
subject subsection so
all nodes that are one node away
from there
so there's information in the nearby
nodes but also the nearby edges that we
want to incorporate into our central
node so it can gain useful context from
its surrounding regions
we then want to kind of aggregate that
information
and use it to update the representation
of the node so that it has a an enhanced
representation
so a couple of steps that are needed to
achieve
this and the general idea is known as
message passing
so let us consider the situation of node
5
which wants to get information from node
3 and node 6.
for each node we gather the values
of the neighboring nodes we aggregate
them in some way sum a mean and max i
think here is the sum
and then we pass them through an update
function which is typically a neural
network that we can train
and the new representation can have a
different number of dimensions so three
go in but one could come out or more
could come out depending on how you want
to encode the information
and when you train this network it will
then
effectively learn to pass on the useful
features from the neighboring locations
and ignore the useless ones
so
mathematically why so this to kind of
link the matrices that we defined
earlier with this concept of message
passing just want to very quickly make a
mention of this
so at the top we have what's known as
the polynomials of the laplacian
and in the example below we have the
first order polynomials where
omega 1 is set to
1 and everything else is set to 0
and when you work through the
calculations you'll see that that
results in a node
getting information from nodes that are
one distance away
if we set omega two to one and the rest
is zero
then we then aggregate from two nodes
away
and this allows us to
control how much information we want to
pass to our node
whether we want to pass it from one node
away two nodes away or just two nodes
away or potentially even more
and we do this in a layered way so
if i if i do one step of the first order
i get information from one node away
if i do that same step again then my
node will get information from two nodes
away and so on
and a bit like kind of convolutional
neural networks the architecture is
it's not as well defined as it is in the
image recognition case where we can just
use other architectures from
what's been defined
and so determining the optimal number of
layers
and the optimal kind of
architecture
is
it's still kind of yeah an area of
research it's not fully defined
and you also want to make sure you don't
find too many layers because then you
dilute your graph and then
it's effectively like blurring an image
to the point that it's a single color
so this is the end to end process that
we have we start off with a graph
we go through a number of layers where
we encode
where we do this message passing process
and then we end up with a new
representation for our graph
and then once we have our new
representation we can then put that into
a
very typical classifier and
train our task
and at the point of the change
representation our
our nodes our data points have gained
useful context from their neighboring
regions
so we saw how the initial framing of the
problem didn't allow us to make use of
the relationships between our data
points
but now with this graph representation
and the layers we've defined
we can encode this information we've
used the local structure of the graph to
pass information to other regions of the
graph
sometimes we may be doing a node
prediction task but all the information
is encoded in the edges in which case
the the message passing that we want to
do is from edges to nodes and vice versa
if we want to do an ed projection task
but our nodes seem to contain the
information then you want to transmit
that information from the nodes into the
edges
slightly more complex when you do it
that way because as mentioned earlier
the dimensionality of our edges and
nodes are different
there's two approaches to overcome this
the first one is to create some mapping
between the two spaces
or just to
concatenate your
features which is usually easier
so trying to
create these representations without
graph theory as cumbersome
and i hope the general measure is at
least a little bit clear behind the
logic of why we do this
and how we can define our problem as a
graph
but ultimately the core assumption has
to be there are some relationships
between our data points that are
significant enough that we have to go
through the hassle of doing this
so performance wise
most research papers now just compare
different graph approaches with each
other the earlier ones in 2017 2018
included comparisons between graph
approaches and non-graph approaches
which is quite interesting
so in this paper they do this task of
predicting traffic flows
on the top part of the graph you can see
some of these performance measures the
map and the rmse
and you can see they're a little bit
higher than what we can now achieve with
graphs
the bottom one being the latest
innovation at the time
which is a significant improvement over
yeah previous approaches that don't
encounter this
so now to spend a bit of time talking
about the practical side of this the
technologies and the processes of
getting something like this working
the application is not only for data
scientists but also data engineers
because getting something like this
working the notebook is fine but then to
productionize it with smooth pipelines
machine learning pipelines is not as
straightforward as they might be with
other models and approaches we use
but as i mentioned earlier the tools to
support this are pretty mature
so for for your database uh neo4j is
probably the most well-known graph
database
aws and gcp i believe office managed
services of this so you don't need to
hire some specialized graph database
engineer
i think aws also has neptune its own
version of a graph database so
i'm not sure how that fits into their
ecosystem
and effectively the difference between a
traditional database is that we restore
the relationships explicitly in the
database so usually when you write to
the database it takes longer
but then at the query time it's quicker
because
well as as shown by here if we want to
get a list of
customers who bought certain items in
this query above
you can see we have to define the joins
and the query below we don't explicitly
define the joins we just define the
relationship between our two entities
and this has some advantages in your
processing
because these relationships are already
defined
um and you don't need to take existing
tabular data and do some horrible
processing to it which
which kind of gets into the format we
need
so that's the first step
but now we also need process data
now this is a tool that perhaps divides
some opinions
a few groans muttered every time it
comes up but spark
graphics is a component within spark
that supports
processing graph data
for example if you're defining the
connections in your graph
let's say we're in a supermarket and we
want to see which items are brought
together
but from the data it's probably clear
that actually almost every item is
brought together but we want to ignore
the ones which have such weak signals so
we need to then filter our graph
that's where graphics comes in
makes that makes the processing data
easy pretty easy
and finally a library to actually help
you get more hands-on with the models
pytorch geometric
really good documentation endless
notebooks there to help you get started
and want to also make a mention to a
more niche library pie torch geometric
temporal
so if you can imagine we've been talking
about graphs now just static graphs but
graphs can also evolve
and so this library combines the
kind of graph theory also with the
concept of recurrent neural networks
so it enables you to capture the spatial
element
in your problem
but also the temporal
so space and time
i think einstein would be proud
it's a much smaller library i don't
think it's quite production ready yet um
but they are looking for contributors so
maybe interesting if someone is
interested in graphs and wants to
contribute to such a library
so one of the main takeaways from this
talk i hope is that graphs can be useful
in some situations
they can encode tricky parts of our
problems that previously we may have
ignored
and with that i yeah open the floor for
some questions thank you
thank you very much
okay can we open the floor to any
questions
hey um very nicely delivered talk thank
you um i've got a quick question uh very
uh
maybe niche as well but um i've got
lots of data that would be really
suitable for graphs but it comes sort of
in the form of
an adjacency matrix but it's really
noisy
is it really sensitive to that so for
example in your bike example i'm not too
certain if the bike came from mayfair or
westminster
um but it's like that across the board
would it be too sensitive for that or no
uh
so you you say you have a
data set in which you have this
adjacency matrix yeah
okay
but the
uh
the nodes themselves yeah are very noisy
so like i've got some noise between
westminster and mayfair oh and it could
be you know it could be this or this
um is it sensitive to that noise or is
it would it be okay in dealing with it
it would be okay in dealing with it but
it would slow things down because it's
it's going to be very low signals that
then get propagated so you it's better
to zero them out
okay
depends on the sensitivity of your task
as well
maybe you cannot zero them out
for example if you're if you're
analyzing fraud then yeah maybe maybe
you don't remove data points
but if it's for a traffic case then it's
not so sensitive
brilliant thank you very much i'll make
my way around the room
uh thanks for the presentation um i mean
i've missed it but then i was just
thinking um how does this work in cases
where you have um super nodes in the
graph
say particular nodes that have lots of
connection with other smaller nodes
say you want to make predictions for
such nodes does this mean that
you wouldn't be able to make the actual
accuracy prediction since now they are
connected to a lot of other nodes and
also for cases where you have um smaller
nodes without lots of connections as
your say super nodes and would i call
them sub nodes if that's these are these
nodes of the same type or you have like
two categories of nodes same type okay
so i was just asking how does this fare
well for such type of nodes
with lots of connections with other
notices
it depends on what the relationships are
it's fine to have like nodes which don't
have a lot of connections
um and yet super nodes for example in
the social media setting you can imagine
there's a few users who have lots of
followers and those followers don't
really have any people are following
them
um and it works quite well in that case
so i don't think there's an issue with
uh yeah having these super nodes like
you say
but it also depends on what the
relationships are
but the answer is it depends
okay i had a question over here
hey thank you for the talk um regarding
this message passing um in your
experience how much time or how
difficult is it to tune that right so
how to come up with one signal from your
features or maybe doing a weighted
approach or
yeah so um
the best way to do this
i find is to look at the literature and
see what architectures are being used
for similar tasks
so
[Music]
in traffic prediction certain networks
have certain architectures in the fraud
case other architectures seem quite good
um so it depends on your kind of use
case so
in the case of the fraud for example you
can imagine there's lots of transactions
that happen between people that are like
15 16 17 nodes away but you still want
to incorporate that
but then it's quite hard because certain
points of the graphs are really far from
each other and they never share
information so what you usually do in
that situation is by having some kind of
like hybrid node that exists and a layer
above
and at each at each step every node
sends that super node or a combination
of supernodes some representation and
then that gets shared across back to the
other notes
and so
yeah it depends on your problem but
there are ways uh around that
and so that's that's an example of how
you would solve that problem
but maybe
yeah we can speak afterwards as well to
go into more detail
all right really interesting talk um
quite a new area for me so sorry for
this too simple question um there are
some circumstances where you'd want to
know
the if i keep counting how many bikes
should be at station one versus station
two if a thousand people cycle this way
a thousand people cycle this way that's
great if you just looking at the state
of montreal it will cancel out but if
you actually want to look at congestion
on the road you'd be treating that
differently how would you handle those
things differently
by handling the case that people are
traveling in different ways so in some
cases i'm i'm only interested in the
actual count of the bikes at the
stations and in some cases i'm
interested in what the traffic flow on
the road is yeah so how how could you
differentiate those two different things
by having two separate features which
defines you just do some flows yeah
all right we'll have two more questions
yeah thanks for the talk my question is
kind of related so if you had because in
your problem you described just demand
at each node but if you had origin
destination information um so you knew
like how many bikes went from mayhem
mayfair to tower bridge
how would you how would you sort of
encode that information
on top of the problem that you described
um
[Music]
so
that would be a relationship between
those two nodes because now you have
there's well there's people traveling
via the bike schemes uh between these
locations but it's also people traveling
via other modes as well
and so all of this contributes towards
potential demand at the location the
more people that go to this particular
location the more likely it's going to
be used that's going to contribute
towards demand
so when you encode information on the
edges like i mentioned you would encode
yeah
things like distance but also people
traveling between the two via train
traveling between the two via the bike
scheme and other modes
one more at the front here
thank you
um yeah thanks a lot really good
presentation
um just i don't know if you can just uh
briefly just uh kind of clarify um
towards the end you talked about node.js
graphics and i think um
py torch yeah geometric are those
um
three different ways of representing i
mean i mean i've used node.js you know
as a way to sort of from a database you
can get graph and then i wasn't too sure
and you mentioned graphics yeah so is
that another way of
sort of representing graphs um using py
um
neo4j is for storing data okay uh spark
graphics is for processing relations
pre-processing
yeah and then the pi torches for the
models itself oh right i see so the
models they need data in a certain
format
and of course where it's stored and how
it is you need something in between two
to match those and that's where spark
comes in okay thank you
so that is all the time we have for
questions today but if you could all
help me and thank you for a truly
enlightening talk